Jerry what's up buddy hey Rich how you
doing I you got a lot of callers so I'll
make it quick I want to just give a
share it and ask so you know I have
experience with a lot of these boss
babes and you know they're the same
every time you know and
um you know they they deal with a lot of
simps and then they come across the guy
that has their act together and you know
can handle business and you know it um
triggers an anxious trauma response in
them and they confuse it with love and
you know they start acting in ways that
you know
um they just don't understand what
they're doing in the
um
they make choices that they wouldn't
normally make
um because they are confused because
they've had so many guys that have you
know taken them out and treated them a
certain way and they have it in their
head that yeah like I said they're
actually delusional
yeah you know when it's
um it's really kind of hard to watch you
know and you know you you have a couple
glasses of wine with them and you have a
lot of fun in the beginning but you know
eventually you know they're pretty much
crying in the shower I mean it's really
what happens
um you know they have their Gucci
handbags in it it's all really fancy but
um it's pretty much a house of cards and
you know the question I have for you
tonight you know if you were a woman or
if you know you could put yourself in
your daughter's shoes like or what would
you want for your daughter I went to the
zoo this weekend with my kids and
there's these good-looking women you
know they're dressed really nice and
they have these real nice strollers and
they got a latte and they have a nice
diamond ring on their finger and it was
it was the weekday and you know they
look like they're having a good time
would they rather be at the zoo pushing
their you know kids around looking good
having a good time or would they rather
be sitting in traffic you know heading
to the office so I mean
what did you answer that question what
do you think
that's not really a question that's
that's what women have aspired to do and
be for ever it's just the last 20 30
years you know you know women have been
sold this constant bill of goods which
is
you know smash the patriarchy climb the
corporate ladder get you know get
degrees make money buy houses pay taxes
get 27 000 handbags for yourself because
you don't need no man and a woman needs
a man like a fish needs a bicycle so you
have a lot of these boss girls you have
a lot you know a lot of these Becky's
out there
um I'm sure you see them a lot of the
time when you're dating right you know
they got their own they got their life
sorted out they got a cool job and a car
they think is cute and you know they're
cute little Ikea sort of setup in their
house and their fluffy white dog named
Bartley or something like that you know
one that I see a lot is is they have an
extra room and then an extra room is
like 20 boxes of [__] they need to take
back to return you know they buy this
stuff online and they got a big big day
of you know repackaging to send us up
yesterday but hey I'll I'll let you go
hey good to see you thanks a lot thanks
man yeah appreciate it yeah it's yeah
it's a fact you know that and that in
that room full of [__] that he's talking
about with all the stuff to returns
I saw that a lot like
um
you know I put I put that as one of the
red flags in my um uh 20 red flag
chapter my first book
and it's
it's basically addictive personalities
and you know you can be addicted to
cigarettes you can be addicted to booze
you can be addicted to drugs you can
also be addicted to shopping and you can
be addicted to buying [__] and returning
it
um which is one of the things that I
made mention of and you know like as you
get older and you start dating these
beckies you'll notice there's a lot of
them out there and they'll go out and
they'll buy like you know they'll go to
the the home cents or the winners or you
know whatever it happens to be where you
live the targets or whatever and they'll
buy like seven decorative lamps and lamp
shades bring them all home try them out
beside their Ikea couch and end table
and then the one they like they'll
they'll keep and then they'll go and
return the other five or six of them
right and it's like
you know they spend their life in a
store buying and and returning stuff
paying taxes on it and this is their
version of Smashing the patriarchy right
they don't want to serve a man at home
they don't want to serve a family they
don't want to raise you know uh kids
they don't want to be a mother and a
wife like women today want to have kids
but they don't want to be a mother and a
wife they just want to drop their kids
off at the daycare and you know hop on
uh
choo-choo train you know downtown
and you know go and make their money and
pay all those taxes
is what it is right I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out